तो चलिए, एक वास्तविक बातचीत करते हैं।  अगर मुझे
शून्य से शुरुआत करनी पड़े, बिना किसी बचत, बिना किसी
निवेश, बिना किसी वित्तीय सुरक्षा के, तो
मैं क्या करूंगा?  शून्य से शुरुआत करना, नए सिरे से शुरू करना
बहुत चुनौतीपूर्ण हो सकता है, लेकिन
स्पष्ट इरादे और
स्पष्ट रणनीति के साथ यह संभव है।  तो आज के वीडियो में
मैं इस बारे में बात करने जा रहा हूं कि
अगर मुझे बिल्कुल
शून्य से शुरुआत करनी होती तो मैं क्या करता।  कोई शर्म नहीं, कोई
आलोचना नहीं, और कोई अनावश्यक बातें नहीं।  मुझे बस स्पष्ट रूप से यह बताना था कि
अगर मुझे दोबारा शुरुआत करनी पड़े तो मैं क्या करूंगा।   चलिए शुरू करते हैं।
सभी को नमस्कार, मेरा नाम
बोला शोकी है।  मैं क्लेवर फाइनेंस का संस्थापक और सीईओ हूं।
मैं
क्लेवर गर्ल फाइनेंस पुस्तक श्रृंखला
और अपनी सबसे हाल ही में प्रकाशित पुस्तक, चूज़िंग टू
प्रॉस्पर की लेखिका भी हूँ।  क्लेवरर्ल फाइनेंस टीवी में आपका स्वागत है।
तो, अगर मुझे बिल्कुल शुरुआत से शुरू करना होता, तो
मैं यह करता।  सबसे पहले
मैं
अपने मौजूदा आंकड़ों पर अच्छी तरह से नजर डालूंगा।  तो, मैं यह
जानना चाहूंगा कि मेरी वर्तमान आय कितनी है?
मेरी आमदनी कितनी होगी?  क्या यह
अनियमित या नियमित आय है?  मैं
अपने खर्चों को समझना चाहूंगा।
हर महीने कितना पैसा खर्च हो रहा है?  अगले कुछ महीनों के लिए
मुझे किन चीजों के लिए आवर्ती आधार पर या
एकमुश्त भुगतान करना होगा?
मैं यह भी पता लगाऊंगा कि मुझ पर कौन-कौन से कर्ज हैं और
उन कर्जों की वजह से मुझे कितना खर्च करना पड़ रहा है।  और मैं यह
भी देखूंगा कि मेरी मूलभूत आवश्यकताएं क्या हैं।
मेरी मूलभूत आवश्यकताओं की लागत क्या है
जिससे मैं अपने जीवनयापन के लिए आवश्यक चीजों को खरीद सकूं और फिर जीवित
रहने की स्थिति में आ सकूं?  और इसका
मूल रूप से मतलब है कि मैं अपने भोजन,
आवास, परिवहन, बुनियादी
उपयोगिता बिल और
अपने परिवार को आवश्यक दवाओं आदि का खर्च उठा सकूँ।  उदाहरण के लिए,
मेरे बच्चों को साल भर
एलर्जी रहती है।  इसलिए, अपने
आंकड़ों को ध्यान से देखने से मुझे यह समझने में मदद मिलेगी कि,
ठीक है, बोला, तुम शून्य से शुरुआत कर रही हो,
लेकिन तुम्हारी वित्तीय स्थिति वास्तव में कैसी है
?  आपकी
वर्तमान वित्तीय स्थिति क्या है?  और इससे
मुझे अपना अगला कदम तय करने में मदद मिलेगी।  मेरे लिए,
इस समय किसी भी बात को मीठा बनाकर कहने का समय नहीं है
क्योंकि स्पष्टता के बिना मैं कोई योजना या रणनीति नहीं बना सकता।
इसलिए,
मेरे लिए यहाँ महत्वपूर्ण बात यह है कि मैं स्पष्टता प्राप्त करूँ
ताकि मैं अपना ध्यान केंद्रित कर सकूँ और अपने
इरादे निर्धारित कर सकूँ।  दूसरी बात, मैं अपने
खर्चों को न्यूनतम आवश्यक चीजों तक सीमित कर दूंगा।  फिर से
याद रखें, मैं शून्य से शुरुआत कर रहा हूं और
इसलिए मैं खुद को संभालने,
अपने पैरों पर वापस खड़े होने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं, और भले ही मेरी
आमदनी अधिक हो, फिर भी मैं
केवल बुनियादी जरूरतों पर ही ध्यान केंद्रित करूंगा।  इसलिए, मैं अब
सर्वाइवल मोड में जा रहा हूं ताकि मैं
खुद को संभाल सकूं और
चीजों को वापस पटरी पर ला सकूं।  इसलिए,
जीवित रहने की स्थिति में आने के लिए, मैं
सभी गैर-जरूरी खर्चों पर रोक लगा दूंगा।  इसका
सीधा सा मतलब यह है कि
नाखून बनवाने या
बाल संवारने से संबंधित कोई भी काम मैं
थोड़े समय के लिए खुद कर सकती हूं।  मैं उन
स्ट्रीमिंग सेवाओं की सदस्यता रद्द कर दूंगा और उनका उपयोग नहीं करूंगा जिन्हें मैं नहीं देखता या
उपयोग नहीं करता, ताकि मैं जितना हो सके उतना पैसा
बचत करने में लगा सकूं।  मैं
घर पर खाना बनाऊंगी।  मैं बाहर से खाना
मंगाने या खाने पर पूरी तरह से रोक लगा दूंगा।  एक बार फिर,
यह सर्वाइवल मोड में बुल्ला है।  मैं
भावनात्मक या सुविधा के लिए की जाने वाली खरीदारी को भी बंद कर दूंगी।
इसलिए, मैं खुद को
थोड़े समय के लिए
कपड़े या सौंदर्य प्रसाधन खरीदने के लिए मॉल जाने की अनुमति नहीं दूंगी।  मेरे पास
घर पर इसकी पर्याप्त मात्रा है।  और मैं प्रति
सप्ताह खर्च की एक न्यूनतम सीमा निर्धारित करूंगा।
असल में, मैं इससे ज्यादा
खर्च नहीं कर सकता और मैं इसी पर कायम रहूंगा।  और
असल में, ऐसा करने के पीछे जो कारण
मैंने पहले बताए थे, वे ये हैं कि मैं पूरी तरह से
स्पष्ट रूप से नए सिरे से शुरुआत करना चाहता हूं।
और इसलिए हां, मुझे अपने
बाल संवारना बहुत अच्छा लगेगा।  मुझे अपने नाखून बनवाना बहुत अच्छा लगेगा।
लेकिन व्यक्तिगत रूप से, मैं
उन चीजों को कुछ समय के लिए रोक दूंगा ताकि मैं
खुद को संभाल सकूं, कुछ बचत कर सकूं
और फिर वापस उन पर काम शुरू कर सकूं।  तो जब आप
अपने बारे में सोच रहे हैं, अगर आप नए सिरे से
शुरुआत कर रहे हैं, अगर आपको नए सिरे से शुरुआत करने की जरूरत है
, आप खुद को ऐसी वित्तीय स्थिति में पाते हैं
जहां आप जानते हैं कि चीजें
ठीक नहीं चल रही हैं और आप शून्य से शुरुआत कर रहे हैं
, तो आपको जीवित रहने के लिए किन चीजों में कटौती करने की जरूरत है
ताकि आप
अपने पैरों पर वापस खड़े होने के लिए पैसे बचाना शुरू कर सकें
?  ये मेरे लिए स्थायी चोटें नहीं हैं।
ये अस्थायी कटौती हैं और आपके लिए
ये केवल अस्थायी कटौती होंगी
ताकि आप फिर से पटरी पर आ सकें।  जब
हालात थोड़े और स्थिर हो जाएं, तो आप
अपनी पसंदीदा चीजें फिर से करना शुरू कर सकते हैं
और खुद को भी लाड़-प्यार दे सकते हैं।  इसलिए, खर्च में
कटौती करके और केवल
जीवित रहने के तरीके को अपनाकर,
मैं वास्तव में अपने खर्चों पर बहुत ध्यान केंद्रित कर पाता हूं
और हर एक डॉलर को
प्राथमिकता वाली चीजों पर खर्च कर पाता हूं।  तीसरी बात, मैं
तुरंत पैसा कमाने के अवसरों पर ध्यान केंद्रित करूंगा।
ध्यान रहे, मैंने त्वरित धन कमाने के
अवसरों की बात की है, न कि रातोंरात अमीर बनने की
योजनाओं की।  यहां अंतर है।  तो,
मैं खुद से पूछता था, मैं
जल्दी से पैसा कैसे कमा सकता हूँ?  मैं
कुछ पैसे कैसे कमा सकता हूँ जिससे मुझे बचत करने
और फिर से
अपने पैरों पर खड़े होने में तेजी लाने में मदद मिले?  और मैं यही करूंगा।  मैं
अपने घर में पड़ी अनुपयोगी वस्तुओं को बेचने पर विचार करूंगा।  तो, तकनीकी सामान, कपड़े।  मेरे
पास बहुत सारे कपड़े हैं, फर्नीचर है जिसका
इस्तेमाल नहीं हो रहा है, बच्चों का पुराना सामान है,
मेरे गैरेज में भी चीजें हैं, मेरे तहखाने में भी चीजें हैं।  मैं
इन चीजों को बेचने के लिए बहुत ही रचनात्मक तरीके अपनाता था, मतलब ऐसी
चीजें जिनका मैं उपयोग नहीं करता या जिनकी मुझे
अब जरूरत नहीं है, ताकि अतिरिक्त पैसे कमा सकूं।
और मैं ऐसा ईबे, फेसबुक मार्केटप्लेस जैसी जगहों पर करता था
, यहां तक ​​कि गैराज
सेल भी लगाता था या अपने स्थानीय कंसाइनमेंट स्टोर में सामान ले जाता था।
मुझे
अपनी क्षमताओं के आधार पर कोई सेवा प्रदान करने के बारे में भी सोचना चाहिए
, है ना?  हो सकता है कि मैं
Task Rabbit या इसी तरह के किसी प्लेटफॉर्म पर कोई सेवा प्रदान कर सकूं।
मैं
उन सेवाओं को प्रदान करने के संदर्भ में अपने कौशल का उपयोग करूंगा।  तो,
उदाहरण के लिए, फ्रीलांसिंग, कोचिंग,
भाषण देना, ये ऐसी चीजें हैं जिनमें मैं
व्यक्तिगत रूप से बहुत अच्छा हूँ और मैं
वहाँ अपनी सेवाएं प्रदान कर सकता हूँ।  बस
अपने बारे में सोचना शुरू करो।
आप किन-किन कौशलों से पैसा कमा सकते हैं?  इसलिए, मैं
एक अंशकालिक काम की तलाश करूंगा जिससे
मुझे अपने
पूर्णकालिक व्यवसाय के अलावा शायद टिप्स भी मिल सकें।  इसलिए, आपके लिए यह
एक पूर्णकालिक नौकरी हो सकती है, लेकिन
फूड डिलीवरी या उबर चलाना आदि जैसी चीजें
अतिरिक्त आय अर्जित करने में सहायक हो सकती हैं।
और मैं छोटे व्यवसायों
को वर्चुअल एडमिन सेवाएं प्रदान करने के बारे में भी सोच सकता हूं
क्योंकि एक छोटे
व्यवसाय के मालिक के रूप में, मैं जानता हूं कि छोटे
व्यवसाय कैसे काम करते हैं और मैं निश्चित रूप से
वहां मूल्य जोड़ सकता हूं।  इसलिए लक्ष्य
पूर्णता प्राप्त करना नहीं है।  लक्ष्य यह है कि आप
अपने पैरों पर फिर से खड़े होने के लिए प्रगति करें।
और इनमें से कुछ बातें शायद आपको
अजीब लगें, जैसे कि BOA ऐसा क्यों करना चाहेगी
?  लेकिन याद रखें,
इस परिदृश्य में मैं शून्य से शुरुआत कर रहा हूं।  मैं अस्तित्व बचाने के लिए संघर्ष कर रहा हूँ।
मैं ज्यादा से ज्यादा पैसे कमाने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं
ताकि मैं अपने बिलों का भुगतान कर सकूं।  मैं फिर से
अपने पैरों पर खड़ा हो सकता हूँ।  मैं दोबारा बचत करना शुरू कर सकता हूं और
अंततः निवेश करना शुरू कर सकता हूं क्योंकि अभी
मेरे पास कुछ भी नहीं है।  तो, यह सब
रचनात्मकता दिखाने और
अपने कंफर्ट जोन से बाहर निकलने के बारे में है।  मैंने कई
सालों से कोई छोटा-मोटा काम नहीं किया है।  अगर मुझे
पैसे कमाने की जरूरत है, तो यकीन मानिए मैं
बाहर जाकर वो सब कुछ करूंगा जिससे
पैसे आ सकें।
चौथी बात, मैं एक शुरुआती आपातकालीन
निधि बनाऊंगा।  इसलिए, एक बार जब मेरे पास पैसा आना शुरू हो जाता है, तो
मेरी पहली प्राथमिकता
अपने पहले 500 डॉलर, अपने पहले 1,000 डॉलर
और फिर अपने पहले 1,500 डॉलर को अलग रखना होता है।  और यह
आपातकालीन निधि
मुझे थोड़ी मानसिक शांति प्रदान करेगी
क्योंकि 1,500 डॉलर से मेरे यूटिलिटी बिलों का भुगतान हो जाएगा।  इसमें
भोजन की व्यवस्था करना भी शामिल हो सकता है।  इसमें
कार की साधारण मरम्मत करवाना,
टायर बदलवाना,
आपातकालीन हवाई टिकट खरीदना जैसी चीजें शामिल हो सकती हैं।  1,500 डॉलर, भले ही बहुत बड़ी
रकम न हो, लेकिन
अगर आपके पास आमदनी होती रहे तो इससे बहुत कुछ किया जा सकता है।
इसलिए, मैं आपातकालीन निधि को प्राथमिकता दूंगा
और जब तक मैं इसमें और पैसे जमा नहीं कर लेता, तब तक इसे अपने बफर खाते के रूप में इस्तेमाल करूंगा।
और
यह वह पैसा नहीं है जिसे मैं
अपने चेकिंग अकाउंट में रखूंगा।  इसलिए, मुझे इसे खर्च करने का मन नहीं करता।
मैं इसे एक
अलग खाते में रखूंगा जहां से मैं इसे आसानी से निकाल सकूं
, लेकिन मेरे पास कोई
चेक या डेबिट कार्ड नहीं होगा जिसे मैं अपने बटुए में रखूं
और
जब भी मुझे लालच आए तो उसे स्वाइप करता रहूं।  पांचवा विकल्प, मैं
एक सरल और लचीला
बजट बनाऊंगा।  और सरल से मेरा मतलब सचमुच
सरल है।  और यह मेरा 50
3020 का बजट है।  और मूल रूप से,
मैं अपनी आय का 50%
आवश्यक वस्तुओं पर, 30% लक्ष्यों, बचत,
ऋण चुकाने पर और 20% लचीलेपन या
छोटी-मोटी इच्छाओं पर खर्च करूंगा, क्योंकि इस नए सिरे से शुरुआत करने की प्रक्रिया के दौरान
, आप थकावट का अनुभव कर सकते हैं।
और मैंने अपने
लिए 50:30:20 का बजट इसलिए चुना है क्योंकि नए सिरे से
शुरुआत करने के इस दौर में
चीजों को जटिल बनाने की कोई जरूरत नहीं है।  यह एक
बहुत ही सरल और प्रभावी बजट है।
हालांकि, आप इस 50:30:20 के अनुपात को
अपनी स्थिति के अनुसार संशोधित कर सकते हैं या आप अपने लिए सबसे उपयुक्त तरीके के
आधार पर प्रतिशत को समायोजित कर सकते हैं।
इसलिए, आप
70 20 10 का बजट बनाने का निर्णय ले सकते हैं।  तो,
उदाहरण के लिए, आप 8020 बजट बनाना चुन सकते हैं।
इस समय आपकी जरूरतें और खर्चे बहुत अधिक हो सकते हैं।  तो,
हो सकता है कि 80% आपकी जरूरतों पर खर्च हो रहा हो,
लेकिन फिर आप 20%
अपने लक्ष्यों जैसे बचत,
कर्ज चुकाने या निवेश करने के लिए अलग रख लें।
इसलिए, आप इस बजट को
प्रतिशत के हिसाब से समायोजित करना चाहते हैं ताकि यह आपके लिए काम करे और
इसे यथासंभव सरल बनाया जा सके ताकि आप
अभिभूत महसूस न करें और
जटिल बजट को समझने की कोशिश में थक न जाएं, खासकर अभी के समय में।
वैसे, अगर आपको यह वीडियो पसंद आ रहा है, तो कृपया
इस चैनल को सब्सक्राइब करें।
अह, क्लेवर गर्ल
फाइनेंस की वेबसाइट देखें।  हम 30 से अधिक
पूरी तरह से मुफ्त पाठ्यक्रम और 40 से अधिक
पूरी तरह से मुफ्त वर्कशीट प्रदान करते हैं।  आप
हमारे पॉडकास्ट, जिसका नाम Clever
Girls Know है, को भी सुन सकते हैं, चाहे आप कहीं भी
पॉडकास्ट एपिसोड सुनते हों।  और
अपनी सबसे अच्छी सहेलियों को भी क्लेवर गर्ल फाइनेंस के बारे में बताना न भूलें।
और
Clever Finance पुस्तक
श्रृंखला को देखना न भूलें।  इस श्रृंखला में पांच पुस्तकें हैं
, जिनमें मेरी नई वर्कबुक '
माई वेल्थ प्लान' भी शामिल है।  ठीक है, चलिए
वीडियो पर वापस आते हैं।  छठे विकल्प के तौर पर, मैं
ऋण चुकाने की योजना चुनूंगा।  इसलिए, अगर मुझे नए सिरे से
शुरुआत करने के साथ-साथ कर्ज से भी निपटना होता, तो
मैं निम्नलिखित में से किसी एक को चुनता।
मैं या तो स्नोबॉल पद्धति को चुनूंगा
जिसमें मैं अपने ऋणों को न्यूनतम
राशि से अधिकतम राशि तक व्यवस्थित करूंगा और सबसे
पहले अपने सबसे बड़े ऋण को चुकाने को प्राथमिकता दूंगा।   सबसे
पहले मैं उस कर्ज को सूचीबद्ध करूंगा जिसका बकाया सबसे कम है।  या फिर मैं
हिमस्खलन पद्धति को अपनाऊंगा, जिसमें मैं अपने
कर्ज को उस कर्ज के आधार पर व्यवस्थित करूंगा जो मुझे सबसे ज्यादा महंगा पड़ रहा है।
इसलिए, जिस कर्ज पर
ब्याज दर सबसे अधिक है, मैं उस
कर्ज को न्यूनतम भुगतान से जितना
संभव हो उतना अधिक चुकाने को प्राथमिकता दूंगा।  इसके बाद, मैं
अपना सारा कर्ज व्यवस्थित करने
और उसे चुकाने के लिए अपना तरीका तय करने के बाद अपना फोन उठाऊंगा,
चाहे वह
स्नोबॉल विधि हो या एवलांच विधि।  मैं
अपना फोन उठाऊंगा और अपने लेनदारों को फोन करूंगा, अपने
ऋणदाताओं को फोन करूंगा और बेहतर
ब्याज दर, समायोजित भुगतान
समयसीमा, और यदि संभव हो तो कठिनाई अनुरोध (
यदि उनके पास कठिनाई
कार्यक्रम हैं) के लिए बातचीत करने की कोशिश करूंगा, यह सब मेरी वित्तीय स्थिति के आधार पर होगा।
कर्ज के मामले में एक बात हमेशा ध्यान में रखनी चाहिए कि
आप हमेशा बातचीत कर सकते हैं।
बातचीत की गुंजाइश हमेशा रहती है।  और अगर
आप ऐसा नहीं भी कर पाते हैं, तो सबसे बुरा जवाब जो आपको
मिल सकता है वह यह है कि नहीं, यह आपके लिए उपलब्ध नहीं है
और आप अपनी बनाई हुई योजना के साथ आगे बढ़ सकते हैं।
लेकिन अगर आप
कर्ज से जूझ रहे हैं और आपको लगता है कि आप
भुगतान करने में असमर्थ हैं, तो निश्चित रूप से अपना फोन उठाएं
और अपने ऋणदाता को कॉल करें और
कठिनाई योजनाओं के बारे में पूछें, भुगतान स्थगित करने के बारे में पूछें ताकि वे
आपके क्रेडिट पर नकारात्मक टिप्पणी करना शुरू न करें
क्योंकि आपने उन्हें अचानक छोड़ दिया है।  आप
बातचीत करना चाहते हैं।  आप
बातचीत करने की कोशिश करें और फिर अपनी
योजना को लागू करें और अपनी आय
और
बनाए गए बजट के आधार पर, आप
अपना कर्ज चुकाना शुरू कर सकते हैं।  सातवीं बात, मैं
हर दिन पैसे के बारे में सीखना शुरू कर दूंगा।
और यह वाला बहुत बड़ा है।  इसका
कारण यह है कि ज्ञान ही शक्ति है।  अगर मैं बिल्कुल शुरुआत
से शुरू कर रहा हूं और मेरी
वित्तीय साक्षरता में कमियां हैं, तो मैं जितना हो
सके उतना सीखने पर ध्यान केंद्रित करूंगा।  और मैं हर
दिन 10 से 15 मिनट ऐसे काम करता था जिनमें मैं
अपने पैसे का प्रबंधन करना, सही ढंग से बजट बनाना और
क्रेडिट कैसे काम करता है, इसके बारे में सीखता था।  मैं
निवेश की कार्यप्रणाली के बारे में सीखूंगा।  मैं
अपनी आय बढ़ाने के तरीके सीखूंगा।  और मैं वास्तव में
दीर्घकालिक धन सृजन करना सीखने को प्राथमिकता दूंगा।  मैंने जो कुछ भी
सीखा है, उसे मिलाकर मैं
अपने लिए दीर्घकालिक संपत्ति कैसे बना सकता हूँ ताकि
मुझे कभी भी दोबारा शून्य से शुरुआत करने की स्थिति में न आना पड़े?
और क्या?
वित्तीय साक्षरता के बारे में सीखने या
अपने वित्तीय साक्षरता
कौशल में सुधार करने की बात आती है, तो क्लेवर गर्ल फाइनेंस के पास 30 से अधिक
पूरी तरह से मुफ्त पाठ्यक्रम हैं।  हमारे पास
40 से अधिक पूरी तरह से मुफ्त
वर्कशीट हैं।  और एक पुस्तक श्रृंखला भी है
जिससे आप शुरुआत कर सकते हैं, जो आपको फिर से
अपने पैरों पर खड़ा होने में मदद करेगी।  और मैं
मानसिकता में बदलाव लाने पर भी ध्यान केंद्रित करूंगा।  असल में मैं खुद से
कह रहा हूं कि नई
चीजें सीखकर मैं
अपने लिए नए परिणाम हासिल करूंगा।  आठवीं बात, मैं
स्वचालन स्थापित करूंगा।  और इसका
मूल रूप से मतलब है कि मैं अपने वित्त के जिस भी हिस्से को स्वचालित कर
सकता हूं, उसे स्वचालित कर दूं, खासकर अगर मेरी
आय स्थिर है।  इसलिए, मैं
बिल भुगतान को स्वचालित कर दूंगा।  इस तरह मुझे इस बात को लेकर
मानसिक
कसरत नहीं करनी पड़ेगी कि क्या देय है और कब
देय है।  और मैं
अपनी बचत को स्वचालित करने को भी प्राथमिकता दूंगा, भले ही वह केवल
5 डॉलर प्रति सप्ताह हो, हर दो सप्ताह में 10 डॉलर हो, या जो भी
राशि हो।  मैं एक निश्चित
राशि को स्वचालित रूप से बचत खाते में जमा करने की व्यवस्था करूंगा
ताकि मैं
समय के साथ बचत करने की नियमित आदत विकसित कर सकूं।  जैसे-जैसे
मेरी आय बढ़ती है, मैं
स्वचालन के माध्यम से और भी अधिक बचत कर सकता हूँ।  इसलिए,
बचत को
नियमित रखने और
बिलों का भुगतान समय पर करने के लिए स्वचालन एक बेहतरीन तरीका है, ताकि आप
बिलों का भुगतान देर से न करें।  और अध्ययनों से पता चलता है कि जब
आप प्रक्रियाओं को स्वचालित करते हैं, तो आप औसतन उन लोगों की तुलना में अधिक पैसे बचाते हैं
जो ऐसा नहीं करते हैं, क्योंकि
जब आप प्रक्रियाओं को स्वचालित नहीं करते हैं और आपकी
तनख्वाह आपके बैंक खाते में आ जाती है, तो
बचत करने का मौका मिलने से पहले ही कोई न कोई खर्चा आ जाता है।
हमेशा कोई न कोई व्यवधान होता है, हमेशा कोई न कोई बिल होता है।
हमेशा कोई न कोई ऐसी चीज होती है जिसकी
वजह से आपको पैसे खर्च करने पड़ते हैं, है ना?
हालांकि, अगर आपने इसे स्वचालित कर दिया है, तो
पैसा अपने आप आपके बचत खाते में चला जाता है।
इससे पहले कि आप सोच पाएं,
"क्या मुझे
यह खरीदना चाहिए? क्या मुझे यह खरीदना चाहिए या नहीं
? मैं बाद में बचा लूंगा। मैं इसके
बाद बचा लूंगा। XYZ," यह पैसा अपने आप आपके निवेशों और बिलों में चला जाता है।  आप
खुद
से उन बातचीत को शुरू करने का अवसर ही नहीं देते
क्योंकि पैसा पहले ही
आपके भविष्य के लिए स्वचालित रूप से अलग रख दिया गया है।
नौवीं बात, मैं
जितनी जल्दी हो सके निवेश करना शुरू कर दूंगा।  इसलिए, एक बार जब मेरे
पास आपातकालीन
बचत के लिए कुछ धनराशि अलग से रखी हो, और मेरी आय
स्थिर हो जाए, तो मैं अपने रोजगार के प्रकार के आधार पर एक रोथ
आईआरए, एक पारंपरिक आईआरए या एक 401के खाता खोलूंगा।
और
मैं
निवेश शुरू करने के लिए थोड़ी-थोड़ी रकम लगाना शुरू करूँगा।  निवेश शुरू करने के लिए आपको बहुत अधिक धन की आवश्यकता नहीं होती है।
आप बहुत कम मात्रा से शुरुआत कर सकते हैं।
और
समय के साथ निवेश करके धन बनाने की कुंजी
निरंतरता बनाए रखना है।  जैसे-जैसे आपकी आय
बढ़ेगी, वैसे-वैसे आप अपना
निवेश भी बढ़ाएंगे।  और
निवेश करने की सबसे अच्छी बात यह है कि
जब आप सो रहे होते हैं तब भी आपका पैसा आपके लिए काम कर रहा होता है।  और
ऐसा इसलिए है क्योंकि
निवेश के
अच्छा प्रदर्शन करने पर आपके पैसे पर चक्रवृद्धि लाभांश का प्रभाव पड़ता है और साथ ही
निवेश के मूल्य में वृद्धि भी होती है।  और
मैं सरलीकृत
निवेशों पर ही ध्यान केंद्रित करूंगा, जो मूल रूप से
कम लागत वाले इंडेक्स फंड या ईटीएफ जैसी चीजें होंगी
जो मुझे व्यापक विविधीकरण और
न्यूनतम जोखिम प्रदान करती हैं।  दसवां नंबर, मैं
अपनी जीत का जश्न मनाने के लिए बिना किसी अपराधबोध के ब्रेक लूंगा।
इसलिए, नए सिरे से शुरुआत करना कोई आसान काम नहीं है।
यह मुश्किल होने वाला है।  आपको
खुद को धैर्य और नरमी देने की जरूरत होगी।
आपको असफलताओं का सामना करना पड़ सकता है।  चीजें
योजना के अनुसार नहीं हो सकती हैं, लेकिन
जब तक आप इरादा तय करते हैं और
प्रगति करते रहते हैं, वही मायने रखता है।
और इसलिए जैसे-जैसे मैं उस यात्रा पर आगे बढ़ रहा हूँ,
प्रगति कर रहा हूँ, निर्धारित
चरणों में आने वाली बाधाओं का सामना कर रहा हूँ, मैं
अपनी जीत का जश्न इस तरह से मनाने के बारे में सचेत रहूँगा जो सार्थक हो, और
जो
मुझे मेरे लक्ष्यों से भटकाए नहीं।
इसका मतलब यह हो सकता है कि मैं
हर हफ्ते अपनी पसंदीदा कॉफी पी सकूं, अपने
नाखून बनवा सकूं या कुछ ऐसा कर सकूं जिससे
मुझे अच्छा महसूस हो, खुद को कुछ ऐसा तोहफा दूं
जिससे मुझे अपनी प्रगति पर खुशी महसूस हो, लेकिन
मेरी
प्रगति में कोई बाधा न आए।  यह वास्तव में महत्वपूर्ण है कि आप
अपनी जीत का जश्न मनाएं और
खुद को आगे बढ़ते रहने के लिए प्रेरित करें क्योंकि
वित्तीय यात्रा में ऐसे समय भी आते हैं जब
आप निराश महसूस कर सकते हैं, आपकी
भावनाएं कमजोर हो सकती हैं और आपको बस
एक प्रोत्साहन की आवश्यकता हो सकती है।  और अपनी
जीत का जश्न मनाकर आप खुद के लिए भी यही कर सकते हैं।
हम
वित्तीय स्थिति में सुधार करने, नए सिरे से
शुरुआत करने या यहां तक ​​कि धन बढ़ाने के मामले में अनुशासन के बारे में बहुत बात करते हैं।
हालांकि, अनुशासन का अर्थ
अभाव नहीं है।  इसका मतलब
सजा नहीं है।  आप इस यात्रा के
दौरान भी जीवन के छोटे-छोटे सुखों का आनंद लेना चाहते हैं
, है ना?  और इसलिए मैं
अपने लिए उन चीजों को शामिल करता था जिनमें मुझे कोई अपराधबोध नहीं होता था।  और मैं
आपको
भी उचित सीमा के भीतर ऐसा करने के लिए अवश्य प्रोत्साहित करता हूं।  इसलिए यदि आप
आज शून्य से शुरुआत कर रहे हैं, तो आपको
फिर से शुरुआत करनी होगी, बिल्कुल
शुरुआत से, यह समझ लें कि यह
आपकी अंतिम मंजिल नहीं है।  यह आपके द्वारा
उठाए गए पहले नए कदम हैं, जो आपको
किसी अलग जगह, किसी
बड़ी जगह, किसी विशाल जगह तक ले जाएंगे, ऐसी जगह जो
आपको अंततः सशक्त और खुद पर गर्व महसूस कराएगी।
इसलिए
हतोत्साहित मत होइए।  निराश मत होइए।  इसका
पुनर्निर्माण संभव है।  फिर से शुरुआत करना संभव है।
शून्य से शुरुआत करके कुछ अविश्वसनीय बनाना संभव है,
कुछ ऐसा जिस पर आपको बहुत गर्व होगा।  इसलिए
आज से ही एक कदम से शुरुआत करें।  अपनी आर्थिक स्थिति को सुधारने
के लिए आप आज कौन सा एक कदम उठा सकते हैं
?  और फिर आगे बढ़ते रहिए।
और फिर अपनी जीतों का हिसाब रखें।
अपनी सेहत के बारे में लिखें।  जब भी
कुछ अच्छा हो, उसे लिख लें।
यह जरूरी नहीं कि यह कोई
बहुत बड़ा या भव्य आयोजन हो।  लेकिन ये छोटी-छोटी
जीतें बहुत प्रेरणादायक होती हैं।  और समय बीतने के साथ,
जब आप पीछे मुड़कर अपनी प्रगति को देखेंगे
, तो आपको एहसास होगा कि आप कितनी दूर आ गए हैं।
क्योंकि कभी-कभी जब
आप पुनर्निर्माण की प्रक्रिया में होते हैं, तो
प्रगति को देखना तब तक मुश्किल होता है जब तक
आप पीछे मुड़कर यह न देख लें कि आप कितनी दूर आ चुके हैं।
इसलिए, अपनी उपलब्धियों को दस्तावेज़ित करके
, आप ठीक यही कर पाएंगे।
इसलिए, मैं चाहूंगी कि आप कमेंट्स में बताएं कि
अगर आप बिल्कुल नए सिरे
से शुरुआत कर रहे हैं या
आपको नए सिरे से शुरुआत करनी पड़ रही है, तो अपनी आर्थिक स्थिति को फिर से सुधारने के लिए आज आप पहला कदम क्या उठाने वाले हैं।  हो सकता है कि आप जो
साझा करें उससे किसी और को भी प्रेरणा मिले जो नए सिरे से
शुरुआत कर रहा हो।  मुझे उम्मीद है कि आपको
यह वीडियो उपयोगी लगा होगा।  अगर आपने ऐसा किया है, तो
कृपया इस चैनल को सब्सक्राइब करें,
नीचे दिए गए लाइक बटन को दबाएं, अपनी
सबसे अच्छी सहेली को क्लेवर गर्ल फाइनेंस के बारे में बताएं
, और हमारी
वेबसाइट पर जाकर हमारे 30 से अधिक मुफ्त
कोर्स, मुफ्त वर्कशीट देखें और साथ ही
एक बिल्कुल मुफ्त मेंटर
कॉल शेड्यूल करें।  तो, क्लेवर
फाइनेंस द्वारा दी जाने वाली सुविधाओं में से एक यह है कि
कोर्स के लिए साइन अप करने पर आपको मुफ्त मेंटर कॉल की सुविधा मिलती है।  इसलिए, हमें
आपसे बात करके और आपकी यात्रा में आपका समर्थन करके खुशी होगी।
यहां आने के लिए धन्यवाद और
मैं आपसे अगले वीडियो में बात करूंगा।
[संगीत]